on parle de pluie de pluie de pluie oui
ce printemps qui tarde à se manifester
ici au québec et ça d impact très
concret pour ceux qui vivent du
jardinage par exemple les chiffres
d'affaires sont en chute libre dans le
secteur et des passionnés prennent vous
allez le voir leur mal en patience
vincent maisonneuve avec le printemps
qui se fait attendre
les clients sont rares dans les
pépinières du grand montréal il ya les
inconditionnels les pouces verts
toujours fidèle au poste et des
suspendus m'ont hélas à l'intérieur
laissant le jour gérante la nuit mais le
temps maussade des dernières semaines a
refroidi l'intérêt des jardiniers du
dimanche
rares sont ceux qui ont la tête à
préparer leur jardin ici les ventes sont
en forte baisse
c'est une baisse de 30% conduit en ce
moment c'est désastreux legend of chun
pour les affaires et fait miroiter en
outre ménard en raison des nuits
fraîches serge dion a dû chauffer
davantage les serres ce qui a fait
grimper les coûts de production mais
avec un coût qui fait que ça baisse ne
profite malheureusement les affaires
tournent également au ralenti à la
pépinière jasmin situé à montréal
ici aussi les clients sont rares et
l'absence de soleil freine la croissance
de certaines plantes
c'est un des pères printemps qu'on a vu
depuis plusieurs années mais la saison
est encore jeune
le mois de mai est toujours le plus
lucratif quelques week-ends chaud et
ensoleillé pourrait encore tout changer
on se croise les doigts par le passé on
a réussi à prendre ce genre de déficit
l'an mais il faut que la température
soit de la partie ce qui va arriver
malheureusement c'est que
sa voiture étant maintenant alors les
gens vont arriver ils vont vouloir
servir ce fonds doit avoir les attentes
auxquelles il serait un peu plus long
pour savoir vraiment où tu as des buts
tout en même temps alors ça ça fait plus
de l'algérie c'est en espérant que jours
le printemps arrive ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal